okay so um today I wanted to expand on
the topic of wives and sheep's clothing
so these are women that maybe have a
husband like a wife they have a ring
like a wife they might even look the
part of a wife but they are not wives
and the reason they are not wives is
because they do not have the mentality
of wives and they typically teach their
daughters wrong women between the ages
of roughly 35 to 55 years old are what I
would call the worst wives we have ever
had in history it is the last generation
of women that got married in their 20s
and 30s and typically they really all
LED their daughters astray and gave
terrible dating advice um so an example
of a wife in sheep's clothing is this
woman right here what relationship
advice would you give the youth what
relationship advice like romantic yeah
come on you're what your love you're one
what would you say you know what this is
what I would say and I know this is
probably what I I tell this list to my
daughter that you are the love of your
life that's right and I think that when
you start with yourself loving yourself
creating boundaries advocating for
yourself being honest with yourself not
being so good that you're not being
honest you know especially as a woman
then I think everything grows from there
it is the greatest seed you can plant in
the world to create great friendships
and relationships is To Love Yourself
there's nothing greater than a woman
that has confidence and this one had it
and uh We've created this relationship
that's just beautiful so we're just
thankful it's my dude okay so now a lot
of people want to come at me they say
pearl you're not married and look fair
enough right but what I do is I look for
patterns and Trends in society of what
works and what doesn't work now is this
woman an expert the CEO of marriage
because she's married she's been with
this guy is she now should she give
relationship advice my intention is not
to say that I have all the answers but
my intention is to show you what doesn't
work this woman had no words about
serving her husband and serving her
family her only words were about serving
herself self-centered women may be able
to have relationships at some point
however they typically fail and they
either fail because the man becomes a
shell of himself or they fail because
they get divorced and nothing will keep
her happy this Dynamic does not work she
looks like a wife she's married like a
wife but she doesn't have the mentality
of a wife the husband nods along to this
craziness and doesn't guide her no
wonder we are so confused and it would
be interesting to look at what this
woman's daughter looks like in her
relationship outcomes because if I had
to predict something is going to be off
with the kids when there is a super
masculine mother typically Al something
is out of order with the children unless
it unless it is corrected but typically
like this type of relationship I would
expect without knowing without even
seeing what her kids look like her kids
to be similar to Will and Jada's
children so the comments weighed in on
this mindset Mike says a relationship
will work best with a masculine and a
feminine it doesn't matter who takes the
role we can see that here yeah and I
would argue that it does matter it
really does I don't think that masculine
women make good wives and mothers
typically the kids will be out of order
Bradley says there's a male Boomer
phenomenon where his wife will
emasculate him in front of an entire
dinner party and he'll just chuckle like
she's a firecracker that one I married a
real pistol yes and this is what I'm
talking about it's the wives and sheep's
clothing they look like wives but they
don't have the mentality of a wife as
true femininity is selflessness true
femininity is serving your me the men in
your life and your family it is not this
me me me love yourself idea and if that
worked then we would see happy
relationships left and right because
women love serving themselves first in
2023 out of the wives and sheep's
clothing I have identified three types
of modern mothers so so the first modern
mother is the you can have it all mother
now these are mothers that are adamant
that they must have a career yes they
cannot not have a backup plan their need
for comfort and the Safety and Security
of a backup plan overrides their kids
need for a mother they either want a
career for the attention and grandios of
having a career and being able to say
they were successful or they want the
career as a backup plan because they're
told Often by their mothers that the men
will just leave you high and dry and
abuse you if you don't have a backup
plan um an example of this I wanted to
draw attention to a woman I covered this
woman a couple of months ago her name's
Ursula Burns she is the first black
female CEO of a Fortune 500 company and
achieved her success through a
combination of career dedication and a
supportive family Network she credits
her rise to success partly Outsourcing
children to trusted members of her
community including her husband and her
sister this enabled her to take on
numerous leadership roles including
serving as the CEO at zerox which that
company I used to work in col cier sales
that company's going downhill if there
was if there was if I had to sell a
copier and they had Xerox I was like yes
yes sign me up because I could I could
steal their customers the easiest
anyways that's just anecdotal I have no
idea how they're doing now this was
years ago anyways um chairing the White
House National stem program and holding
positions on the board of companies like
uber and American Express Burns didn't
conform to the idea of being a super mom
acknowledging that balancing her career
and family required a differ approach
she didn't attend all her children's
events and sometimes relaxed even
working on puzzles during their
activities while controversial to some
her use of the term Outsourcing spark
debates while some argued that many
parents rely on help from their
Community but might not label it as such
however critics pointed out that Burn's
approach might not be feasible or
relatable for to many black women
especially considering the challenges
faced during Co Dawson highlighted the
struggles of black working mothers
during the pandemic emphasizing that the
options available to Burns a decade ago
differ greatly than what many face
post-pandemic despite her successful
career Burns acknowledges a sense of
Detachment from certain aspects of her
day-to-day life due to Rapid career
Ascent expressing some regrets about not
being more present in those moments
overall she credits her family's
approach to child care as pivotal and
raising too well adjusted kids though
she recognizes the trade-off that it
came with her career focused approach so
again this is out of order now why is
this out of order these are women that
put their career above their family they
are not there for the little things they
are not there for their kid in the
school play they are not there for
basketball games they are not there to
pick up their kids from school they are
not there to help their kids with
homework these little things matter and
they matter to Children you cannot
replace a mother and a father typically
these career women have to marry
somebody on their level now I could
actually support career women if they
accepted what came with it became the
bread winner and let the dads stay home
so the kids have somebody watching them
but typically these women want the
career and they want a husband that
makes more than them so who is watching
the kids who is watching them because
you cannot Outsource Parenthood you
cannot Outsource being a mother many
times I'll often see these women have
grandmothers rais the children they want
a career they need to go for this so the
grandmother raises the kids and what I
see these women often reference is that
usually there would be tribes and all
these women would come together and
raise the kids now I'm not discounting
that that happened at times but those
mothers were still more involved than
you will be working 40 to 60 hours a
week in 2023
there are so many atome jobs that there
really is very little excuse to not be
there to raise your children children
need parents and these women prioritize
money and they think if they have money
that the kids will be okay often times
what you see with these parents are Jada
and will type kids where they're very
left very liberal very free spirit and
don't typically go on to be happy
healthy and married um so the next wife
in sheep's clothing that I see is women
that put sexuality above their children
these women care about getting sexual
attention and validation from men more
than they care about their children
because they don't stop to consider
their children's feelings from their mom
posting thirst traps on the internet
many of these women will have only fans
many of these women will chase after
athletes actors and entertainers to be
their step down Daddy for a lifetime
these women will have random men in and
out of the house
constantly with no regard for the safety
of their children the most likely person
to abuse a child is actually the
stepfather but these mothers do not care
because what they care about is getting
sexual attention and gratification from
men an example of this mother is Lana
rhods I saw Lana rhods on a podcast
recently talking about how much she
loved being a mother well what was your
experience like with only fans yeah so I
think um I think only fans is great um
having come
from professional porn I think it's
great that so many sex workers now
have mostly the control handed back to
them obviously there's still going to be
exploitatory people in that industry as
well but in most cases it's a lot better
for the girls and so I just you know I
was doing it for so many years at this
point there wasn't any anything wrong
with only fans I just was like I don't
want to show my tits right now anymore
like I'm just tired of it and I really
want to have a kid and so I was trying
to figure out a way to make income
without doing any type of sex work so
when I got the opportunity to work with
Logan and Mike it it just made sense and
it helped us all tremendously at the
life point that we were in and so it was
sort of that was the transition in the
Avenue away from any type of sex work
yeah and I I I'm about to go go back
into only fans okay um but I have not
done any type of only fans or any type
of sex work really for 3 years now was
it scary to leave it behind or did it
feel good or was it both what was that
like for you I had other goals like
having a kid so when I finally was able
to supplement my income without having
to show myself or be sexualized in any
way it was really relieving I I'm not a
very sexual person so having to put
myself out there in that way is
generally uncomfortable for me okay
so notice how she says her goal was to
have a kid and now she's a single mother
it was not to find a husband it was to
have a kid like think about how out of
order that is okay she takes three years
off of sex work then she gets the
opportunity to be an influencer these
women never want to do hard jobs they
never want to actually do what it takes
to not put their ass on the internet
interet and they always go back to it
that's why men get so frustrated when
you get these girls that do these ho
apology tours because they always end up
going back when they actually have to do
work half of these chicks are just too
lazy to work a normal job McDonald's is
hiring you could waitress you could
serve you could I'm sure there's a
library hiring down the street from you
but they want Easy Money they've never
had to do what it takes to earn hard
money because they've always monetized
their beauty in some way she even talks
in this episode about how much she loves
being a mom okay and do you like being a
mom now I love it it's the best the best
thing that's ever happened to me besides
like I I still have some of the health
issues which obviously sucks but I
wouldn't ever take it back like my son
has changed my life in the best ways
possible I I I wouldn't ever even go
back to the person that I was before
so I guess it it did Lead Me in all
directions to where I like I like where
I am now better that's great a lot of
things have changed for me mentally over
the past few months I recently started
medication I got proper diagnosises I've
been doing a lot of work of my mental
health but since Having My
Baby I have struggled probably from the
worst mental health issues that I have
in my entire life just like debilitating
I've spent the past since becoming
pregnant like over two years just in bed
and not living life or functioning like
a normal person besides when it comes to
my son I always show up for him and I
always do everything that I'm supposed
to do and make sure that his life is
great um I always give him the childhood
that I wish that I had and above and
beyond so that he doesn't grow up with
the traumas that I had or um the
personality disorder that I had which
comes from people not um validating your
emotions or punishing you for I'm like
getting so
emotional oh it's okay yeah no I'm um
that's beautiful thank you but it's also
um really remarkable what you've been
through thank you um and it's amazing
that you're taking care of a child and
also trying to take care of yourself
yeah it's really difficult okay there
there's so many contradictions she just
said that's really difficult but then
just admitted that she's been in bed for
three
years you know what's crazy men don't
aren't allowed to have mental health
issues like this because they'll just be
homeless they're not allowed to be in
bed for 3 years the other interesting
thing she says she had a personality
disorder so why does she have custody of
the kid I I don't from what I understand
I think she got pregnant off of an NBA
guy I I think she basically got a kid
out of one because I I don't think that
the dad is too active in their life and
it's interesting because she said she'll
do everything for the bo a boy not to
have trauma but she won't not do only
fans I mean what's more traumatizing for
a kid than having a mom that's on only
fans I don't even think sex workers
should have kids I mean you made
your bed lying it and why if you had a
personality disorder was your number one
goal to get a kid why why would you want
to bring a kid into that um and then you
have the other woman validating her but
see this is what I mean she is addicted
to sexual attention from men she will
never stop and she's just going to go
nuts so again this is a woman that puts
sexual attention above the welfare of
her kids so that's the modern mother
number two modern Mo mother puts her
career above her kids modern mother
number two puts attention from men
you'll also see these women dressing
very provocatively going out to clubs
and bars um which leads me and a lot of
times there's overlap like I would say
Lana rhods is a combination of two and
three which the third type of Mo modern
mother is is the mother that is addicted
to Lifestyle